my name is Greg sterling I'm the Dean of
Yale Divinity School and on behalf of
the Divinity School in the university we
welcome you to our annual Margaret link
with Sorenson lectureship this
lectureship was established in 1978
through the generosity of the honorees
son dr. Andy Sorenson who graduated with
a Bachelor of divinity from this school
in 1962 I had the privilege this fall to
sit n eat lunch with his sister Mary
Beth Sorenson kohler who is married to
David Kohler a member of the same class
unfortunately Andy died unexpectedly
several years ago he led a very
distinguished career after completing
his Bachelor divinity went on to do a
PhD here in medical sociology held
faculty positions at Harvard University
of Massachusetts Johns Hopkins was
Provost at the University of Florida
president University of Alabama and
president of the University of South
Carolina then went to Ohio State where
he unexpectedly and suddenly died he
established his lecture ship to honor
his mother to deal with public life and
ethics and it seems most fitting to me
that on the 50th anniversary of the
Second Vatican Council at the 50th year
that Andy graduated as an alumnus of
this institution that we have one of the
world's distinguished Catholic thinkers
to address us this evening and to
introduce EJ Dionne we i'm going to call
on professor la mensaje who is the D
Willis Jane professor of missions and
world Christianity here at Yale Divinity
School professor sunny
we are delighted and honored to have
with us ej dionne a distinguished writer
and journalist to present the annual
Sorensen lecture EJ Dionne doesn't
really need any introduction to this
company he is distinguished columnist
for The Washington Post and a senior
fellow at the Brookings Institution in
you in Washington DC as well as
university professor at Georgetown
University EJ Dionne is the author of a
very important book why americans hate
politics which one the Los Angeles Times
Book Prize and was nominated for the
National Book Award his most recent book
our divided political heart the battle
for the American idea in an age of
discontent takes up the ambivalence
Americans have about individualism and
community it's lecture tonight our
divided political heart and the election
of 2012 could not be more timely welcome
to
um well thank you so very much for that
kind introduction it was so much nicer
than the one I once got when I was
giving a talk about politics in the
Midwest and the person ended and now for
the latest dope from Washington here's
EJ Dionne so thank you it is it is such
a great honor to be here at Yale it
actually is a tiny partial fulfillment I
always had I was telling the Dean I
always had an ambition to go to Yale
Divinity School in yale law school and I
did neither but it's sort of good to get
a little piece of Yale I this a second
time I've been up here and every time I
visited I've known that was a good idea
to go to Yale Divinity School so maybe
someday you'll see me back it's also
good to see my friend father Tony from
Washington who will correct any
theological errors i make although in a
rather kindly way which is not what
we're always accustomed to when we make
theological errors and it's also i love
all those zero years it's also the 70th
anniversary of the movie Casablanca
which actually raises all kinds of
interesting political questions probably
closely linked with the fact the Vatican
2 happened i think i just want say a
couple things about acumen ism since I
am a Catholic here at Yale Divinity
School to my favorite ecumenical stories
one involves john f kennedy and we all
remember all the difficulties he was the
first Roman Catholic president he was on
the one hand running into anti-catholic
prejudice on the other hand he was
counting on and received an overwhelming
catholic vote there's great debate among
political scientist over whether
Catholicism helped him or hurt him more
i'm on the help him side but a lot of
very shrewd scholars think it net hurt
him but he's still one and two of his
advisors who were very attentive to
catholic issues were theatre sorensen
not the person after whom this lecture
was named and Arthur Schlesinger jr. and
they would they were speech writers for
Kennedy and Kenny had to give some talk
to a Catholic group and they wrote him a
draft together and Kennedy threw it in
their faces and said this
is the most Catholic speech I've ever
read sometimes I think I am the only
Protestant around here said the first
Roman Catholic president the united
states on the other side there's a story
of Bill Clinton is also a true story
where Bill Clinton very much impressed
the Jesuits at Georgetown University and
he was fairly very good at Christian
doctrine and he was good a lot of other
things very charismatic and so a
distinguished Jesuit at Georgetown
called Auto hence called up reach out to
Bill Clinton said he wanted to have
dinner with him and apparently he took
him out to a famous burger place in
georgetown and he SAT across from Bill
Clinton and said Bill you know we have
been talking and we think there would be
a place for you in the Jesuits and Bill
Clinton gave that fantastic smile he
hadn't I wish I could do a good Clinton
he said a father wouldn't I have to
become Catholic first they had
absolutely no idea the bill clinton was
a Southern Baptist but he went on he he
can persuade anyone of anything and did
a great job in this election campaign
the I i thought the original lecture is
going to be in the HR achard eber room
and so i actually thought i would begin
with a famous quotation for maitre d
board but at Yale Divinity School it's
always appropriate to quote a charger
neighbor who had a great influence on me
particularly his book monotheism and
Western culture a long long time ago but
here's what he wrote in the kingdom of
God in America that quote hey Richard
niebuhr institutions can never conserve
without betraying the movements from
which they proceeded the institution is
static whereas its parent movement has
been dynamic it confined men within
within its limits while the movement had
liberated them from the bondage of
institutions it looks to the past
although the movement had pointed
forward though in content the
institution resembles the dynamic epoch
whence it proceeded in spirit it is like
the state before
the revolution now I think this is a
fascinating quote about they were
quotation of a way of thinking about the
relationship between political movements
particularly revolutionary movements and
then the regime's they create afterward
and while a campaign is not like a
revolution I think all of us can
resonate a bit to neighbours words
perhaps especially this year because we
have moved so very quickly from the
broader argument of the campaign to the
very great difficulty of governing on a
deadline described him perfectly I think
as the fiscal cliff to pick up neighbors
language men and women in Washington
after dealing with large questions in
the campaign are confined within the
limits of fiscal problems made even more
difficult by divided government yet I
want to argue that this election
actually was extremely important and
that its results will stay with us for
some time that is because i think this
campaign was the culmination of an
argument the most basic kind of argument
we can have an argument about who we are
as Americans it is also an argument I
want to argue that is deeply embedded in
our national story now the fact is we
Americans are a confusing people and
perhaps especially to ourselves the
self-portraits we create are often
contradictory the products of our
culture our movies are art or literature
all seem to celebrate conflicting values
is our country better personified by the
community loving Jimmy Stewart and it's
a wonderful life or by the rogue
individualism of Clint Eastwood in Dirty
Harry I'm talking about the Dirty Harry
Clint Eastwood not the empty chair Clint
Eastwood here does Woody Guthrie's this
land is your land speak to us more
directly or how about Frank Sinatra's my
way is the American experiment unique
because it recognizes the
importance of solidarity that we see in
John Steinbeck's novels or the sanctity
of Independence as celebrated by Walt
Whitman or Jack Kerouac my book are
divided political heart grew out of my
love for the American story and these
tensions and although the first sentence
of it refers to American decline in our
worries about it it's a distinctly anti
decline asst book and I will get back to
that and it argues is a hopeful book
about our future because i think the
classic American balance in tension
between individualism and community has
helped us out of many scrapes before and
can do so again I love to quote and many
of you have heard this before I suspect
the best line on us I think came from
Winston Churchill who said Americans can
always be counted on to do the right
thing after they have first exhausted
all of the other possibilities it takes
us time but we get there and I should
also say that my book is very critical
of the Tea Party and its view of
politics but it was also inspired by the
Tea Party I believe the Tea Party was
right to go back to the origins of our
country and that those of us who are
more on the progressive side need to
join them in an argument about this
history I think we've been too willing
to leave the American the argument about
American history to our friends on the
right we have been too reluctant to
embrace the American story which i think
in broad terms is a progressive story
should our conservative friends be the
only people who carry around constant
copies of the Constitution in their
pockets and very distinguished law
professor some of you may know Akhil
amar gave me a tour of the Yale art the
museum today and I had a picture in my
pocket which I took out and forgot of
the signers of the Declaration of
Independence so I could take it out at
that moment because i forgot my pocket
copy of the Constitution but our friends
on the right shouldn't be the only
people who carry around the Constitution
they shouldn't be the only people who
quote The Federalist we certainly
shouldn't leave the Declaration of
Independence to the
I'm the most forward-looking politicians
and moral spokespeople in our history
did not do that they understood the
power of the Declaration of Independence
Martin Luther King's I have a dream
speech as many of you know drew its
inspiration from the promises of
American history and the promises of the
Declaration dr. King spoke famously of
that promissory note that had been
handed to african-americans that had
come back stamped as he put it unpaid
insufficient funds it was a very
powerful way to make his case Abraham
Lincoln whom we're celebrating a lot
these days thanks to steven spielberg
his most important political speech
before he became president in the view
of many historians was his speech at
Cooper Union in New York City and his
goal in that speech was to insist that
the founders of our nation ultimately
foresaw as he did the extinction of
slavery in the United States again
Abraham Lincoln made an argument about
our past in order to make an argument
and frame an argument about our future
so what do I mean by R divided political
heart I believe that from the very
beginning Americans have been torn by a
deep but i believe healthy tension
between individualism and liberty on the
one hand and our affection for in quest
for community on the other we are both
of these things we are not only one of
these things and I think too often
especially in recent years we have told
our story almost entirely on the
individualistic side we have emphasized
individual liberty to the exclusion of
our dedication to community inequality
we have not focused enough on how the
Liberty we prize depends upon our
willingness to come to the defense of
each other's Liberty how Liberty depends
upon strong communities energetic
government and a concern for the common
good consider the very first word of the
Constitution of the United States what's
the first word of the Constitution of
the United States and I love asking that
question because I love hearing groups
of Americans say together the word week
we don't do that very often these days
the preamble is a beautiful thing we the
people of the United States in order to
form a more perfect union establish
justice insure domestic tranquility
provide for the common defense promote
the general welfare yes welfare is right
there in the first paragraph of the
Constitution of the United States and to
secure the blessings of liberty for
ourselves and our posterity again
ourselves and our posterity do ordain
and establish this constitution the
declaration is a perfect reflection of
the balance between individualism and
community it begins by describing the
unalienable rights that come from our
Creator to life liberty and the pursuit
of happiness but in the very last
paragraph our founders pledged their
lives their fortunes and their sacred
honor they understood that the Liberty
they were seeking to establish could not
be established unless they acted
together now as our very first negative
political ad it puts it puts negative
advertising in a new light for you
perhaps a positive light just a couple
of things I like to point out remember
Jefferson had that long list of abuses
and usurpations and he makes all of
these charges against the king just a
couple of facts about those that list
taxation doesn't even show up until
number 17 and the declaration is not
about opposing taxes it's it
demonstrates the British crown for
imposing taxes on us without our consent
the consent was the issue not taxes
themselves and the first two items are
criticized the King because he has
refused his assent to laws the most
wholesome and necessary for the public
good the founders were not
anti-government zealots they wanted us
to govern they wanted a government that
could govern now there was one great
anti-government line in in the
Declaration it's the number it's abuse
number ten and I want to just share it
with you because I love the way it
sounds
they accuse the king in this way he has
erected a multitude of new offices and
sent hither swarms of officers to harass
our people and eat out our substance eat
out their substance now I think of all
the negative ads that mr. Rove or the
Koch brothers put on the air none of
them came close to that language and I
think the next time around they should
study the deck would be Declaration and
they might do a little better we've had
a parallel argument related to the role
of government in our history and I have
spent a lot of time lately with the
legacies of Alexander Hamilton and henry
clay and Abraham Lincoln some of you may
have heard me talk and argue politics
with my friend David Brooks on NPR and
when I finished a book I told David that
one of the most exciting things about it
is I finally figured out why David is so
crosswise to current American politics I
said David I doing reading these clay
and Lincoln especially I realize you are
the last living surviving American week
and David absolutely agreed and since
both of us have a certain sympathy for
the Whigs somebody suggested to us that
we organize an event modeled after
Woodstock called wig stock but we
decided that such an event would be the
most boring event in American history so
I promise you that we won't do that but
if you believe the federal government
play little role in the development of
our country you have to read Hamilton
clay Lincoln and a whole lot of other
people out of the American story another
question when was the first american
version of socialized medicine passed
into law well actually it was passed
into law and signed by conservative
president john adams in 1798 john adams
sign the federal marine hospital as the
act creating the federal marine hospital
service it funded hospitals across the
country at retreat sailors who were sick
or got injured on the job one of the
more embarrassing things that's happened
to me in the last several months is I
went on Jon Stewart instead of referring
to the folks protected by that act as
sailors I
for two injured seamen you can only
imagine what Jon Stewart did with that
I'm sorry I had to share that with you
but you know so Adam Stein they
socialized medicine law into Act into
law and there is no record in our store
our history of mass campaigns against
Adams care and if if you believe that
our Constitution is absolutely clear and
can be read only one way and then you
have to confront the fact that within
three years of the enactment of our
Federal Constitution Alexander Hamilton
and James Madison two of its leading
authors and two of its leading
interpreters we're at each other's
throats over whether the federal
government had a right to establish the
bank of the united states that fight
over what the Constitution said was the
origin of really of our first party
system when we divided between
Federalists and Jeffersonians my chapter
on the constitutional book is called one
nation conceived in argument and I
couldn't resist quoting my friend the
legal scholar garridebs who recently
published a book a very good book on the
Constitution he once said that Justice
Scalia and other original astrud their
jurisprudence in the following idea I
knew the founders the founders were
friends of mine I know how they think in
fact the Constitution was created out of
a series of compromises some of which we
would now very much objec to like the
compromise on slavery it defense
competing values as former Justice David
Souter is said and I think we do
ourselves a disservice in seeing our
founders as unique or sainted people who
received the concert form heaven it's a
disservice because first these were
gifted politicians who who engaged in an
act of enormous political creativity we
have great reason to be grateful to them
but they were also adventurous they were
embarking on a radical experiment for
its time rooted in the idea that people
could govern themselves and so to think
of our Constitution as a set of shackles
designed to keep our country in the same
condition it was in 1787 as a document
that might prevent us from addressing
new problems in new ways
I believe does a disservice to the bold
and adventurous spirit of our founders
Hamilton and clay were visionaries clay
called his program the American system
and what's interesting about that is he
called it the American system to
distinguish it from the British system
which he said was rooted in lazy fair
the American system was different from
laissez-faire we saw a public role
working with the market to turn us into
a prosperous nation by the way fake life
favored a strong federal role in
launching internal improvements and i
would like to launch a campaign to
replace that ugly word infrastructure
with clays very nice term internal
improvements we might fund
infrastructure better if we call them
that and then clay and Hamilton both
foresaw that the federal government
would play a major role in building us
into a great manufacturing nation now
who go on about this history but I just
want to give a taste of that early
period because I think that our friends
in the Tea Party when they argue that we
were a small government nation are
actually not looking at the longer
American story I think they're looking
at an exceptional period on our history
the one period when radical
individualism was genuinely dominant it
was the period of the Gilded Age the
roughly 35 years from say the end of the
Civil War to the rise of both Theodore
Roosevelt and now it should be said that
this radically individualistic period
had an enormous effect it had an
enormous effect on what the Supreme
Court did it was in that period that
corporations were declared people and my
favorite response to that I have to say
came from the distinguished law
professor Stephen Colbert upon hearing
this idea of corporations as people
professor Colbert said that he wanted
his daughter to grow up and marry a
really nice corporation the harbor
Crowley the great progressive thinker
who influences Teddy Roosevelt argued
that progressive sought to use
Hamiltonian means to serve Jeffersonian
ends they wanted to use an active
federal government to ensure greater
equality of opportunity in an economy
me that would not be dominated by the
Trust's or by a very small number of
people those who are looking for
encouragement in our current debates can
just go back to some of the things Teddy
Roosevelt and Woodrow Wilson said when
they ran for president in one of the
great campaigns in our history a hundred
years ago the nineteen twelve election
that's another zero year that we have
reason to celebrate this year they
sounded at times like people walking off
an Occupy Wall Street encampment Wilson
once warned that we were nearing a time
quotes when the power of high finance
would be greater than the power of
government it's astonishing how strong
their rhetoric was and I think what's
important about this story at least as I
see it is that the populace and
progressives rebelled against the Gilded
Age not simply because they were
innovative although they were but and
they did not simply reintroduce big
government I believe they were restoring
the old American balance exemplified by
Clay Hamilton and Lincoln the balance
between individualism and community
between government and the market
between public and private concerns and
for over a hundred years we were
governed under the long consensus
established by these progressives had
helped create the New Deal the Great
Society and what we came to call of the
American Century of the great advances
in civil rights women's rights equal
protection and social justice all
occurred within the context of this long
consensus and in the hundred years after
TR assume the presidency government did
grow but so did individual liberty the
state assumed new worlds but individual
opportunities expanded new regulations
protected the air and the water the
integrity of food and drugs the safety
of workplaces in consumer products and
American capitalism flourish workers
organized into unions that advance the
interests of those who depended upon
their labor not capital for their
livelihood and labor organizations
helped create a more social form of
capitalism based on widespread property
ownership and upward mobility
previously excluded groups were steadily
brought in to the large to larger
American community to share in the
economy's bounty and the
responsibilities of self-government the
US continued to welcome newcomers and we
created the most diverse democracy on
earth now for the last four years and
that's why this election was so
important this long consensus has been
under attack as it has not been under
attack before and I think what she needs
to be recognized is how far many of our
friends in the Republican Party and the
conservative movement I say that
honestly because I have a lot of
conservative friends who might enjoy
arguing with that they have strayed from
their own history and their own past
commitments they have chosen on
principle it could be said to make
middle ground politics impossible they
have done this by jettisoning their
communitarian commitments by adopting a
highly restrictive view of the federal
government's role and by advancing a
view of the Constitution that would
prohibit or restrict activities that the
federal government has undertaken for a
century or more so we talk a lot about
gridlock in Washington when two sides do
not operate within the same framework do
not identify the same problems or don't
and don't even share a common
understanding of our history the
difficulty of finding a chord cannot be
ascribed to pettiness or selfishness or
to a lack of imagination it reflects the
fact that the country has reached a time
of choosing to echo the title of Ronald
Reagan's memorable speech for Barry
Goldwater in 1964 and that is why i
think the twenty twelve election was so
important it was that time of choosing a
few weeks before my book was published
this year my friend my assistant at work
actually would read an early draft I had
some news for me from a Bruce
Springsteen concert how many Springsteen
fans are in the room ah good the yes i
love Springsteen and she came back very
excited from this
conference and she said I had to listen
to this new Springsteen song that she
saw as offering a moving musical summary
of the core themes that I've just laid
out and she also said that it might
serve as a perfect anthem for president
obama's reelection campaign now those of
you who are Springsteen fans know what
I'm talking about I immediately went out
/ purchased Springsteen's wrecking ball
album and found myself listening over
and over as the boss strong and maybe
just a bit plaintiff instructed us
wherever this flag is flown we take care
of our own now my friend was a prophet
and for me an inspiration less important
is the fact that I incorporated the
Springsteen song and talks i gave as I
traveled around the country talking
about this divided heart of ours and how
we had to stop ignoring our community
embracing side I love drawing a
connection between our Puritan past and
our Springsteen present now you may well
ask what in the world does Bruce
Springsteen have in common with Puritans
well let me tell you what he has in
common with Puritans I they never ask
yourself a question you can't answer the
many of you remember that Ronald Reagan
loved to describe the United States as a
shining city on a hill and that Reagan
line came from a speech a sermon by john
winthrop he gave it in 1630 it was
entitled a model of Christian charity
and my favorite line goes we must
delight in each other make others
conditions our own rejoice together
mourn together labor and suffer together
always having before our eyes our
community as members of the same body I
think Rush Limbaugh might call john
winthrop a socialist but when you listen
to that and you listen to Springsteen
they are making exactly the same point
arguably Springsteen in the somewhat
more compact a compact way and and at my
friend will
not only helpful to me it turned out the
Obama campaign independently came to the
same conclusion and we take care of our
own did become a campaign anthem for
those who ever went to an obama rally it
punctured his rallies all over the
country if you stayed up late enough to
watch his victory speech the first words
you heard after he was finished were
Springsteen singing we take care of our
own and I think this was the we take
care of our own election the campaign
ended with Americans reaffirming the
long consensus that I've described this
century long balance to a degree that
surprised even me what a kind of
interest in this the arguments that I've
sort of talked about here I think we're
very much at the heart of the campaign
on the Republican side Mitt Romney's
comments about the 47 about forty seven
percent of us being hopelessly dependent
and his running mate Paul Ryan's past
interest in Iran's philosophy and his
interest in the idea of dividing us
between makers and takers I think very
much spoke to a sense that we were going
back to this some ideas of the Gilded
Age including albeit in a more muted
form some of the ideas of social
Darwinism which took hold in those years
on the other side obama rani explicitly
in defense of government's role in
tempering market outcomes it turned out
that his most controversial and
interventionist policy probably the
policy that came closest to the
socialism that his opponents wrongly
accused him of espousing was also the
most politically beneficial choice he
made I'm referring to the rescue of the
auto industry and absent that action it
is very likely that President Obama
woulda lost Ohio probable that he would
have lost Michigan as well the Midwest
Heartland responded to an approach aimed
at preserving the economic vitality of
communities throughout their region it
was in a way a Henry Clay moment I have
a feeling all the ones you never can
script
its history this way they clay would
have been for the Auto rescue if he had
had any idea what an automobile was the
but this was also the election in which
economic ideas and judgements were not
simply about unemployment and growth
rates it was election about values it
was widely said that our friends in the
Tea Party had transformed the economic
debate into a new culture war and so it
had the makers and takers rhetoric
pointed not to a society defined by
mutuality in which the better off helped
the worse off to escape dependency but
as a nation stuck in a zero-sum game
what was taken from the affluent in this
view was seized by those intense i'm
preserving their own dependent status
now to be sure Mitt Romney and Paul Ryan
tried to take the rough edges off the
rather stark view I have described here
and indeed as Election Day near they
were given more and more to the language
of compassion Ryan even gave a very
interesting speech on poverty that
sought for a brief moment to revive some
of compassionate conservatism themes but
beneath it were those ideas that
animated the forty-seven percent speech
and the release of that speech I think
will prove to have been one of the
campaign's most consequential moments it
froze in place I Romney who had run far
to the right in the in the primaries and
Obama didn't run away from the larger
philosophical argument and he has he had
to some degree earlier on in his
administration in fact the larger
argument about philosophy in the
direction of our country was essential
to ensure that the election would not
hinge simply on unemployment rates alone
and he enlisted as his ally another
Democrat who had understood as well as
he had the rhythms of a politics rooted
in the common good and the idea of
community I am referring to Bill
Clinton's speech at the Democratic
convention in charlotte I just have to
tell you i was there in charlotte as a
journalist as a columnist and I was so
struck that Bill Clinton gay added on
the run 2000 war
words to that speech and the speech went
on and on and that audience in Charlotte
would have happily taken an hour more
and I realized that bill clinton fans
are just like fans of a favorite rock
and roll band they always want the long
version of the song and they were very
happy to have Bill Clinton do it and I
that was I think the moment when the
Obama argument really began to gel
Clinton if you may remember 20 years ago
another zero date had a slogan
opportunity responsibility community and
that's what he talked about in that
speech the clincher line was you see we
believe that we're all in this together
is a far better philosophy than you're
on your own and in his election night
speech President Obama summarized the
argument that he had made over the
previous 15 months if I may quote just a
couple of paragraphs from the
President's speech this country has more
wealth than any nation but that's not
what makes us rich we have a more power
the most powerful military in history
but that's not what makes us strong our
universities our culture or the Envy in
the world but that's not what keeps the
world coming to our shores what makes
America exceptional are the bonds that
hold together the most diverse nation on
earth the belief that our destiny is
shared that this country only works when
we accept certain obligations to one
another and to future generations that
the freedom from which so many Americans
have fought and died for comes with
responsibilities as well as rights and
among those are love and charity and
duty and patriotism that's what makes
America great and I think it does um the
2012 campaign began I think on August
second 2011 that's when president obama
signed the deal ending the deficit
fiasco at that moment i think the
president relinquished his last
illusions that he could make deals with
a conservative movement
was on the track that it had been on
until election day at least and I think
that a Republican majority that was both
inspired and intimidated by the Tea
Party actually was demanding that the
president renounce every principle dear
to him about the role of government in
the 21st century and so you had this
interesting experiment because if the
twenty twelve election was the tea party
at twenty ten election I'm sorry was the
Tea Party's triumph the twenty twelve
election was going to be seal that
triumph or end up being its comeuppance
and I think that that is what it proved
to be now if you want to know where the
you know the the the election was
decided I think that we knew before the
results were in what had happened to
this great debate over government in
many ways Mitt Romney's finest hour was
that first debate and it was deeply
revealing it marked the beginning of mr.
Romney's hard scramble toward the
political middle in the campaign's final
month this was as important a signal
about where opinion in the country lay
as the election result we Romney's
decision to do what he did that night
meant that the newly radicalized
conservative movement in the Tea Party
had lost the twenty twelve election
before the votes were counted and he
Romney would not have tried to move back
from so many of those positions if he
believed that the country were ready to
endorse the full throated conservatism
that he embraced to win the Republican
nomination instead at that moment of the
campaign unlike Barry Goldwater he
sought to be more an echo than a choice
he offered a kind of chorus of me toos
and the fact that conservatives went
along suggested that they had reached
the same conclusion it turned out that
there had been no profound ideological
conversion of the country in 2010 we
remain this
a moderate and practical country we have
long been in 2010 voters were upset
about the economy Democrats word
immobilized and the president was
clearly not yet ready to fight all the
Conservatives had left in October of
this year was economic unease and that
was ebbing and so I think this election
decided a great deal ideas have
consequences is one of the conservative
movements most honored slogans and it's
a good slogan and I think the fact that
in the end the the Republicans had to
escape the consequences of some of those
ideas particularly the idea of radical
individualism tells us what we need to
know about the outcome of this
philosophical battle and for me that
offers us reasons for hope I have
expressed frustration up to this point
over what conservative tis mhmm but I
hope that conservatives might rediscover
both their moderate in their community
rien sides true there are some on the
right that David from the thoughtful
conservative the center has called the
conservative entertainment complex they
wanted to deny some of the lessons of
the election they wanted to blame it all
on Romney or concoct other theories that
require no fundamental rethinking but
most conservatives I think know that
something had gone badly wrong against
all expectations at the beginning of the
year the Democrats not only held the
Senate but actually gained seats their
majority patted by the own goal scored
by tea party candidate semesters Murdock
and akin the Republicans held the House
of Representatives but largely because
of gerrymandered districts and the
concentration of the Democratic vote in
urban areas Democrats actually led the
Republicans in the popular vote in house
race is just a fun fact by almost
exactly the same margin that Al Gore led
in the popular vote in two thousand and
then there was the size of Obama's
triumph it's up to over four million
votes now and victory in every swing
state except North Carroll
I know now many Republicans quickly
concluded that the president's margins
among Latinos required Republicans to
abandon their nativist rhetoric and
wholesale opposition to immigration
reform and that is progress and we'll
see how much progress we make but I
don't think it will be that simple for
the right for one thing a more moderate
sand on immigration could threaten new
divisions in the party and its weakness
among both Latinos and women oh not
simply to immigration or the social
issues but to the fact that both groups
are more sympathetic to government's
role in the economy in promoting upward
mobility than the current Conservative
doctrine allows a party that once the
govern has to do more than run against
government they could do worse than
think about a book by a great Yale
graduate named William F Buckley Jr it
will surprise you but Bill Buckley is
one of my heroes I want to be about five
percent as effective on behalf of my own
ideas as Bill Buckley was on behalf of
his ideas but there was a side to
Buckley that I think we need to pay
attention to now and conservatives need
to pay attention to about 20 years
before he died he wrote a book called
gratitude and in this book Buckley
talked about what we owe back to this
country that had protected us and
nurtured us and I swear that if Bill
Buckley had run in a Republican primary
the founder of the modern conservative
movement had run in the primary over
these last four years on the basis of
the book gratitude he would have lost
the primary I think that's something our
conservative friends should think about
and I think they are take two
conservative columnist Ross Douthat of
the New York Times and mike garson of
the Washington Post here's what we're
all stealth it wrote after the election
what the party really needs much more
than a better identity politics pitch is
an economic message that would appeal
across demographic lines reaching both
downscale white voters turned off by
Romney's Bain Capital background and
upwardly mobile Latino voters who don't
relate to the current GOP fixation on
upper bracket
tax cuts this is Ross Douthat talking
not me he cited another new look
conservative as I have taken to calling
them Henry Olson of the American
Enterprise Institute who argued that
Republicans could find pardon me a way
of opposing an overweening an intrusive
state while still recognizing at olson
as olson put it that government can give
average people a hand up to achieve the
American dream sounds like we take care
of our own to me and then my Gerson
here's just a couple of paragraphs from
my column that Mike wrote some of the
most important intellectual groundwork
is needed on the role of government Mitt
Romney had a five-point plans who
encourage job creation he lacked a
public philosophy that explained
government's valid role in meeting human
needs suburban women heard little about
improved public education single women
particularly single mothers her little
about their struggles apart from an
off-putting Republican critique of food
stamps blue-collar workers in say Ohio
her little about the unique challenges
that face declining industrial
communities Latinos are little from
Republicans about promoting equal
opportunity and upward mobility and this
is Mike some more one more paragraph
neither a vague pro-business orientation
nor Tea Party ideology speaks to those
Americans except perhaps to alienate
them conservatives will need to define a
role for government that addresses human
needs ineffective market-oriented ways
Americans fear public debt and they
resent intrusive bureaucracies but they
do not hate government now those of us
who are on the progressive side harbor
certain skepticism about whether
conservatives can come up with a
plausible program along these lines
without backing away from some of their
fundamental beliefs about the
relationship between markets and
government nonetheless the fact that the
2012 results have pushed so many
thoughtful conservatives toward a new
appreciation of the long consensus I
think can be counted as a victory for a
more balanced and less divisive approach
to politics and governing over the
coming years obama's reelection was at
it's a deeply personal triumph and also
a victory for a younger and highly
diverse and broadly progressive America
that rallied to him it was a result that
ought to settle this bitter argument the
ground the nation's government to a
standstill repeatedly he asked voters to
settle Washington squabbles in his favor
and I think that's one of the things
that happen in this election people talk
about mandates I'm not sure the word
mandate is all that useful I think the
idea that voters settle arguments and
politicians make decide which arguments
they settled helps us more and I think
that is what happened in this election
and so a president who took office on a
wave of emotion I think may have won
something more durable in this election
it was a smaller majority but it was a
majority that had thought hard about his
stewardship had thought hard about what
the argument of the last four years had
meant and decided to let him finish the
job he had become begun yet I don't
think this should be seen as the
beginning as the end of the story I
think this is now the beginning of the
story having one vindication for the
long consensus I think the next
generation of progressives and I see
some of them some of them here in this
room need to prove that the long
consensus is capable of renovation that
it can restore the living standards of
Americans in the nation's industrial
heartland and in the inner cities and in
the abandoned rural areas I think one
thing that both Romney and Obama
supporters had in common particularly
the angriest among them is that they
very much want to rid the nation of this
fear of decline they want a confidence
in the future that is rooted in real
progress and genuine and broadly shared
prosperity I think Obama like Clinton
before him understands the importance of
the nation's communitarian tradition i
think the movement he gathered behind
him does too i think that progressives
and everyone in this room it turns out
remembers that the first word of our
Constitution is the
word we we know that ours is a country
that truly believes that we should take
care of our own and the doing that
requires attention to the world beyond
our borders in the global economy that
is transforming the way economies work
everywhere a community is a noble ideal
but building and strengthening it
requires practical work and the bold and
persistent experimentation that Franklin
Roosevelt commended to us and that is
still the calling of all who would call
themselves progressive I want to close
on two themes one is relates to the
argument that you often have among
Christians since I am at a divinity
school and there's a lot of curiosity
about how is it that an American
evangelical movement that was so
powerfully connected to some of our
strongest progressive traditions has
become significantly more conservative
in recent years we forget that
evangelicals were at the heart of the
fight against slavery northern
evangelicals one should say people in
places like this where I am standing we
forget that William Jennings Bryan who
many people remember primarily from the
movie inherit the wind was a corte was
it's true it was in fact a leading
present politician probably the man who
did more to transform the democratic
party into a progressive party an early
advocate of women's suffrage an advocate
of world peace an advocate of the
income-tax progressive taxation and his
opposition to Darwinism was rooted in
his opposition to social Darwinism which
about which he was right even if he was
wrong about the science of Darwin I
think many things happen to turn the
evangelical movement more conservative I
think in the when the social gospel
movement came along I think many
evangelicals saw that the movement was
more social than it was gospel and that
a a gulf a theological Gulf opened up
between evangelicals and fundamentalists
who had conservative theology and many
of the social gospel errs who had a more
liberal theology when for a very long
time both of these camps had battled
together on behalf of social justice and
those left out and I also think that we
need a dialogue between two kinds of
people you may have had this experience
particularly those of you who are
divinity students I have been struck
that conversations about Christianity
often come down to what people have to
say about Jesus and what Jesus's role
was in their lives and in the world and
you tend to think that you've run into a
more conservative person theological e
and often politically when they respond
that they are devoted to Jesus because
Jesus changed my life and then you run
into more progressive Christians who say
they are followers of Jesus because
Jesus changed the world now there are
many people many people particularly in
the african-american tradition who say
both those things at the same time that
Jesus changed my life and Jesus changed
the world but I would love to just
invite people at this great Divinity
School to have a conversation and it's
it's I've defined it specifically in
Christian terms but I think it's a
larger conversation about spirituality
as well about what spiritualities role
is in transforming individuals and what
his role is in inspiring social change
because again to go back to dr. King I
think some of the most powerful agents
of change in our country's history have
brought a spiritual and often Christian
dimension to a ministry that spoke to
everyone regardless of their faith
including people of no faith at all and
then I have to close by going back to my
friends John Winthrop and Bruce
Springsteen because I think both have
spoken to some of the very best aspects
of what makes us Americans I think we
will honor our past and build a more
secure and just future by remembering
with them that building a nation where
Liberty thrives requires us to stand
with each other and make each other's
conditions our own that is every bit as
papa as much part of our Creed as the
Liberty that we rightly prize and it is
this feeling for each other that will
allow our great national experiment in
self-rule to endure and to prosper thank
you all very much
thank you
thank you
thank you so much
I think it violates the Catholic
tradition to stand between anyone in a
drink but nonetheless I but I would love
to I would love to do QA I by the way i
want to i always like to say i love
dissenting questions my one of my
favorite uncles is someone i argue
politics with for 35 years and his kids
my cousins were kind enough to ask me to
do the eulogy at his funeral and i made
a point of quoting richard nixon in my
eulogy and it was a nixon line i
actually like but as I told the people
in church i quoted richard nixon because
i thought that if he heard me my uncle
ray would come back to life and rise out
of the casket just to tell me I knew
you'd be quoting Nixon some that so I I
welcome to sense thank you for an
inspiring lecture and since you guys up
the Catholic tradition what do you think
has happened to the Catholic tradition
in American politics do I sense a
Catholic tradition in your wonderful
accent to my correct yeah that's that's
a long story as you know better than
anyone the i mean i think that the one
of the things that in the short term has
been forgotten is the role of the
catholic tradition as an engine for
social reform and the role of catholic
social thought in promoting social
reform there's a wonderful writer called
Lou daly who wrote a book called God's
economy that I recommend to you if you
haven't seen it but Lou wrote up
wonderful RSA where he argued that the
Catholic Bishops American Catholic
Bishops 1919 program for social
reconstruction almost perfectly
prefigured the New Deal that it was very
new that Catholic Catholic social
teaching has always had this balance
between an opposition to too much
collectivism you know the Catholic
Church was anti-socialist although
many trade unions ended up allied with
with socialists but it was also critical
of pure market capitalism and so the
Catholic Bishops 1919 program was very
progressive and sought and I think
Catholics the Catholic Social Court has
always been a kind of American third way
if you will and I think sort of Catholic
thinking on economics has always been a
kind of third way and I think it's been
reflected right through to Pope Benedict
in fact in his his first and his
encyclical his social justice and sickle
I had the occasion because the
encyclical came out right before
President Obama visited with Pope
Benedict everyone of course was thinking
what's he going to say to Obama about
abortion I couldn't resist writing a
column saying that the president will
meet with someone whose views on
economics are far to the left of his own
because in fact if you read Benedict's
critique of the workings of pure
capitalism is not anti-capitalist but
he's against pure capitalism now I think
that several things have happened within
the American Catholic tradition over the
last several years one it wasn't simply
Roe versus Wade and the reaction to the
abortion issue within the church because
I think right through the 1980s thanks
to Cardinal Bernadin you know the leader
the president of the bishops conference
great Archbishop of Chicago he developed
his idea of a seamless garment where the
church was pro-life across the board war
as a last resort concerned for life
after birth through natural death not
simply concerned about abortion
opposition to the death penalty any up
through the 1980s the Catholic Bishops
issued two very progressive letters are
more in peace and on social justice but
I think in recent years with the
appointment of more conservative bishops
you have seen some very important voices
in the church argue that the Bernadin
approach the seamless garment approach
was in their view diluting di ll UT
diluting the church
his commitment on the life issues and I
think you also had conservative
Catholics who didn't mind at all pushing
back some on the social justice
tradition in the church alive with them
and I'm sort of defining two groups that
one group where I think they were
conservatives who want to push back
against whole thing the other were
bishops who deeply believed that the
abortion issue the rights a life issue
was foundational to everything else and
wanted to put that front and center I
think from my point of view as a more
progressive Catholic that has had the
unfortunate a couple of unfortunate
effects unfortunately fact number one is
I think it's pushed a lot of young
Catholics out of the church and that's
something I wrote a column about that
this week where I really want the church
to think of the leadership of the church
to think about what message it is
sending two younger Catholics when its
focus is almost entirely on on this this
set of issues and not the broad
traditional church secondly there's not
enough focus on what the church actually
does if I hope she doesn't mind my
daughter who is the senior in high
school spent last summer working at a
Catholic great Catholic program in
Silver Spring Maryland called Shepherds
table and it's a wonderful homeless
program for the homeless run by the
church and she loved everybody who
worked in that program from the person
who ran into the folks who worked in the
kitchen she said there was some of the
best people I ever met and she came home
one night and said why doesn't the
church talk more about this and not some
of the other things that the church
talks about and I just think the church
should bear witness to the work it
actually does in this sphere and I also
think they need to talk with a lot more
compassion when they talk about abortion
asking a carrying a child to term for
nine months is one of the most generous
acts of human being any human being
engages in and I think when we're
talking about abortion we have to
understand what that means what that is
asking of what the commitment to life
actually means what we're asking for
women I think the church should also
think about whether making abortion
illegal would actually have a
substantial effect on reducing the
number of abortions in the country I
think there is an opportunity for
progressives and conservatives
to a lie too we do have too many
abortions in America there are ways of
bringing down the abortion rate many of
the things it would take to bring down
the number abortions would involve
compassion and care for poor families
and particularly poor women and we
should make life easier not harder for
women are going to bring their children
into the world I think after the
election I'm sorry for the long answer
but it's a matter that engages me very
much personally I think after the
election there's a real opportunity i
think that the moon the most
conservative bishops were surprised by
the result i guess they believe some of
the polls that other conservatives
believed i didn't actually believe those
pulse but I could have told him but you
know I think they were actually
surprised by the results Catholics voted
narrowly for Obama partly because of an
overwhelming overwhelming support for
him from Latinos who are the fastest
growing part of the American Catholic
Church and I think that there may be I'm
hoping there's a revisiting of the whole
fight over the contraception mandate I
think there were ways in which that
could be worked out if the bishops want
to do it in the administration's willing
to do it I think there's great room for
cooperation between progressives certain
kinds of compassionate conservatives in
the Catholic Church on immigration and
the church has been at the forefront on
that on that issue and I hope they sort
of worried about young young people like
my daughter and so many other young
Catholics because I think they do not
always present the most attractive side
of our tradition and I think it's a
shame when you push people away from the
gospel so thank you now I'll try to be
shorter thank you very much I'm
Georgetown class of 2011 oh it boy sax
it good to see yes good to see you you
gave a compelling narrative about the
grand consensus of American politics
being this idea that we are our
destinies are united and joined together
I wonder sort of non-economic social
issues on the left how do those four
positions fit into this narrative of our
common
I think for example of the slogans my
body my choice and the government
shouldn't tell us who to marry for those
fit into this narrative and also you
praise communitarianism I'm wondering
where on the Left do you see
endorsements for non-governmental local
civil society where where I said that
laughs on the left do you see those sort
of endorsements of local civil societies
are not on the governmental level well
actually I'm a person on the left to
very much cares about non-governmental
civil society I think that Alan wolf
actually is probably up at BC has
probably written about it more I think
that that just to pick up on your last
point really quickly I think that the
left has within its history a lot of
resources intellectual resources to talk
very sympathetically and positively
about non-governmental civil society
meaning if you look at the early
documents of the new left before it went
haywire in the 60s the whole idea of
participatory democracy that port you're
on statement from sts had a lot of
elements of non-governmental civil
society in it and I you know I am one of
those who believes that the that the
notion of the state cooperating with
religious institutions to promote social
justice and you know to engage in works
of charity is something that can be done
within the confines of the First
Amendment without crossing lines we
don't want the state to cross and
actually if you a friend of mine just
ran the numbers on this see the Obama
administration is actually given more
money for example the Catholic groups
than the previous administration did so
the Obama has done more without talking
about it partly because sometimes it
raises hackles on the liberal side I do
think there is a to go to the first half
for your question on the one hand I
would separate sort of gay marriage from
some of the other issues because i
actually think a marriage is the most
conservative demand the gay movement
ever came up with you know and indeed
when they gave movement you know when
the you know when this first arose
within the gay rights moving a lot of
gay rights
the kids were opposed to it because it
was a kind of concession to a sort of
bourgeois morality and i have i've
argued my friend David Brooks has argued
eloquently that the people who should
most before gay marriage are
traditionalists and social conservatives
because what we ought to want to promote
in our society is fidelity and
commitment and this is demand within the
gay community for a chance to recognize
fidelity and commitment and publicly
honor fidelity and commitment but yes I
think there is an interesting argument
to be had between and I write about this
a lot in the book between a kind of
purely libertarian left and a more
communitarian left now what I try to be
careful about is I'm a libertarian to in
the sense that i believe the personal
liberty is one of the core American
values I just don't believe it is a the
only American at unb I don't believe we
can preserve Liberty without the strong
set of community institutions a kind of
web of mutual support that that's our
that Liberty without community is not
going to last and so much so that's
where I'm more for calling for dialogue
with our libertarian friends and asking
them to understand the limits of
libertarianism even on its own terms and
that's includes areas you know of
sexuality that we that we need to that
we need to address but again if you go
back to the Catholic Church and other
sort of traditional institutions I think
that they're missing a chance to join a
richer conversation in these areas where
I think they can be on the more
communitarian side and again i hope this
election sort of pushes people back a
little and encourages them to rejoin the
conversation a different way from the
way they have up to now could I have one
more I just don't wanna there was it
yeah there was and so one
Oh what do I need a microphone and I
have a long familiarity with the
Catholic Church i worked for Bishop
Fulton sheen for Bishop Sheen machine
you're not old enough to have worked for
bishops almost 70 that's shocking clout
it you your work for the Bishop Sheen
served you well mr. i know it did and i
love that man and at the time he was
working on the second vatican council
when i went to work for him first he was
going back and forth to Rome and at that
time the thing was open up the windows
and let the fresh air in and but I was
just listening to I mean I feel like you
are and it's okay you know to him the
Catholic Church and cause I am however
another victim in the sense of this
closed mindedness which has come on the
Catholic Church on and you know I I was
actually quite shocked when I went in
first and you know after that and after
my divorce which was let's everybody
says it's not their fault
is that I figured you know I'm just
practicing my religion and I was told
you want to go
an annulment then you can come get the
sacraments but that's just we were
talking about gay rights within the
church and I when you talk about
hopefully they'll get the change and
this is my my thing is while John Paul
was considered oh you know just that man
that went out there and his
rockstar however he was ultra
conservative has brought in Benedict and
the thing is that he had a long enough
term he kept in there that almost
everybody is conservative all these
Cardinals and I don't think there's any
hope of change in the near future okay
let me let me let me end this try to
inject an element of hope even though I
agree with some of what use is what you
said about the church first of all I'm
Pope John Paul I think there's a great
paradox about John Paul which is to me
the achievements he had that we will
remember most a hundred years from now
are actually the liberal achievements
and by that I mean the fact that he
ratified some of the changes that were
made by Vatican 2 in relations with
other faiths I mean I I got to cover the
Pope when he visited the Roman synagogue
which was something unimaginable before
Vatican to the fact that he did that the
fact that he condemned anti-semitism in
a very powerful speech sermon I think
that lasts for a long time I think that
the Catholic Church in some fundamental
way switch sides on the issue of
democracy in Vatican 2 and we became
having been skeptical as a church of
democracy in certain important ways
became its advocates I think John Paul
ratified that too so I think on the one
side his greatest achievements will be
in the broadest sense liberal
achievements on the other side you're
quite right in terms of particularly
here in the United States in the last
ten years of his papacy he appointed a
far more conservative group of Bishops I
remember my conservative friends being
overjoyed when he named Cardinal law and
cardinal in New York O'Connor although
O'Connor actually was a great labor guy
and a great social justice guy but you
know at the time people joke that they
were law and order you know and so these
were their friends as well as their
critics and so I think that is another
part of the legacy I like many American
Catholics and especially someone who has
daughters thinks the church really does
need to look again at the issue of
women's ordination and the rights of
women in the church
chennai would like to see that happen
unfortunately takes a very long time for
these things to happen in the Roman
Catholic Church but I do think that when
you look at who is the American church
and I'll just come back home you have
the bishops you have some conservative
bishops I do think they're going through
a certain amount of soul searching in
the election I think there are a lot of
middle-of-the-road bishops who do not
like the way in which things got so
politicized in this election I don't
think they believe the church should be
as clearly aligned as some as the church
was in some diocese around the country
and you have all the people doing work
in places like that homeless shelter
people who do the work for catholic
charities who do work in catholic relief
i mean there is an enormous body of
people who are working inside the church
on behalf of of justice in a deep sense
and i think at some level they at some
point this has to have an effect on the
church itself and you know we all have
our deus ex machina and the great Roman
Catholic deus ex machina and in general
the Christian deus ex machina is the
Holy Spirit who knew that Pope John
would become Pope John who knew that he
would be elected in the first place and
what I want to close on and the reason
I'm glad you brought up Vatican too I've
been sort of thinking of sitting down
with a bunch of Catholic friends
informing the Pope John the 23rd society
and one of the reasons Pope John was so
powerful was in his attitude toward
modernity what I worry very much in the
church now is that we are moving away
from his view a modernity what did he
say he was very critical of those he
called those mistrustful souls who see
only darkness walking the face of the
earth he was very critical of those who
thought that modernity had nothing at
all to teach the Catholic Church and I
think what he preached was the
idea of a dialectical relationship
between the church and modernity where
the church could be on important
questions and I think women's rights to
be one of them could to learn and
democracy was another where the church
can learn from modernity but I think
there are forms of alienation in
modernity and the kind of radical
individualism that I think both of us
are critical of where I think the church
has a lot to teach modernity and so I
suppose in the end i am just betting on
the same Holy Spirit who gave us Pope
John the 23rd to bail us out of our
problems again